er muss nicht wie ich zeit
red
[Musik]
sehr geehrte damen und herren werte
festgäste geschätzte angehörige des
aufklärungs und artilleriebataillons
streik an zu geloben die rekruten ein
altes sprichwort sagt aller guten dinge
sind drei es ist dies die dritte
angelobung in diesem chor ohne jahr 2020
die wir in der kaserne veranstalten
müssen aber sie wird gut werden
ich weiss besser wäre eine angelobung in
den gemeinden des weinviertels mit euren
angehörigen aber ich verspreche euch
es wird ein würdiger festakt werden live
zu sehen im internet
meine sehr geehrten und herren lassen
sie mich kurz ein paar worte zum ablauf
des festaktes verliehen
die angetreten sind 770 rekruten der
stabskompanie die leute angelockt werden
kommandant ist major christian
baumgartner flankiert von zwei
gefechtsfahrzeugen usa und musikalischer
brandt von der militärmusik
niederösterreich unter dem kommando von
oberstleutnant aber ist oben drauf wird
das ein würdiges und schönes ereignis
werden
wir kommen an der ausgeübten druck
als die soldaten die angetretenen
aufgestellt zeichen menge übernommen
lassen sie mich bitte kurz das verlieren
es ist das symbol für den kommerz der
ausgerückten druck jedes dieser truppe
körper hat ein eigenes feldzeichen frühe
fassung eine schlacht war dann gewonnen
wenn man das geld zeichen des gegen
ausbauen konnte nicht nur das
feldzeichen ist die arbeit angetreten
auch die fahne des österreichischen
kameradschaftsbundes des stadtverbandes
mistelbach eine geschätzte damen und
herren der offizielle start des
festaktes erfolgt in kürze mit dem
ankündigungs signal unter meldung an den
brigade kommandant der dritten
jägerbrigade brigadier christian
habersatter gefolgt von der bundeshymne
dem abschreiten der front unter den
klängen des präsentiermarsch es uns der
großen flaggenparade
[Musik]
nein
zur meldung an den private kann man dann
was ganz recht
[Musik]
bradl
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
das ganze geschieht zusammen und herren
ist folgt nun die ansprache quasi das
aussehen des bataillons komponenten des
aufklärungs und artilleriebataillons 3
und kasernenkommandant oberst hans peter
bollig uns danach ein budget von landrat
naja knoten kommen dezember beginnt ein
militärischer rettung nicht unmittelbar
vor ihm das ist ihre mission
trotzdem auf ihrem grundstück werden wir
diese festveranstaltung auch live im
internet übertragen somit begrüße ich
alle ihre angehörigen bekannten
verwandten und freunde auf youtube
gehalten was ganz österreich aus fast
ganz österreich deshalb wie sie
verwenden während unter denkbar beginne
die meisten wir haben zehn männer 16
der grund männer haben zwei jahre
salzburg 250 nicht mehr essen aus dem
burgenland und die masken aus
niederösterreich
wobei auch hier sind wir erfreut über
[Musik]
die jenigen bei uns einige der gesetze
und der gäste aber sich nicht nehmen
lassen
mehr zu schätzen und ich möchte auch
hier einige damen und herren begrüßen
ich bitte dass ich jetzt noch das
unglück machen darf und ich bete dass
wir auf den üblichen applaus zwischen
dort und auch zum schloss verzichten
grühsem einen unmittelbaren
militärischen vorgesetzten werden
präsentiert sie ist dann aber sandner
herzlich willkommen
es ist bei der militärseelsorge ich
hatte gesagt ein grosskampf tag begrüßte
ganz herzlich militärdekan alfred
weidlich alfred aus der stadtgemeinde
mistelbach begrüße ich den herrn
bürgermeister stunden volljährig den
filter bürgermeister heyes kopf manfred
und die stadt dreht den die eigentlich
für auch die wolfratshauser zuständig
ist google
andrea vom stadtmarketing stadt weiter
wissen die frau hat man
die bezirkshauptmannschaft mistelbach
und er ist auch aktiver milizoffizier
der kompaniekommandant uns aber jetzt
kann der joker erben kameradschaftsbund
ist auch an geräten mit einer fahne die
krise hier in bezirksobmann lena johann
und des stadtverbands ob man rufen
arbeiter hier vom hause begrüße ich den
vorsitzenden des rechtsausschusses
vizeleutnant arzt gerhard der obmann der
offiziersgesellschaft
begrüße auch für unser partner firma
volkswagen den seo ingenieur wiesinger
er ist ja auch das wirklich besonders
die militärmusik gesehen werden und am
ersten dezember angeregt es ist noch
nicht so lange her geboten wenn sie
gruppe sehr gute leistungen erbringen
werde ich zwar versprechen einlösen
einerseits dass wir die ausbildung vor
weihnachten abschließen und beschreiben
die zweite sein versprechen wahr dass
sie auch von roland berger was ja auch
gemessen
einen echten schnee gesehen werden auf
diesem weg habe ich sie haben und
schwitzen können ihre ausbildung
abgeschlossen
die schießausbildung erfolgreich
für die erste hilfe ausbildung bei uns
selbst nicht genannt erfolgreich
abgeschlossen und sie haben wirklich
ihre leistung erfragt noch mehr wirkung
war dass sie jetzt ja auch ein kriegs
für die republik österreich für die
gehälter
die meisten haben hier wirklich
erstklassig und ich sage danke ich kann
nur sagen angst hat wenn ich stolz dass
sich auch jetzt geht's nicht und ihre
angehörigen sie können technisch
konzentrieren schon bekannten einsetzen
und sie sagen sogar ich wünsche ich
alles gute der eltern militärischen
laufbahn und sagt immer sie auch
versetzt werden alles und wir behalten
sehr wissenbach in guter erinnerung ich
wünsche ihnen natürlich auch ein frohes
weihnachtsfest ein gutes neues jahr
danke
[Musik]
o
es hätten die ansprache darum
militärische geistlichkeit für die
katholische kirche militärdekan alfred
länglich und im anschluss daran geben
wir dem aufklärer vorne liegen
warum wirklich lästig
die chinesen sind unser zusätzlich
elektronischen intelligenz verfügen sind
heute haben wir schon wirklich der
kindlichen muss grundkraft in
lebensgefahr
die rekruten die angelobt werden haben
am vormittag schon seine reitstunden
lebens religion trägt wir haben einen
tag vor weihnachten
als dieser angelobung melden
unser wegen im füreinander und
miteinander zu gestalten
lasst uns den instant unseren her als
waren dienst des friedens zum wohl
unseres landes verstehen wir uns in der
bewältigung der gestellten aufgaben
stets den tanzenden menschen
in seiner von hier geschenkt würde zu
erkennen und zu achten damit wir in
unserem leben voreinander und wir
bestehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mal
[Musik]
nein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
volt und im anschluss sagen die
traditionsmarke dritten partikeln die
brigade gerade schnell einsetzen
uns lässt vermuten als nächstes spricht
mit der geistlichkeit da würde ich sie
nicht nur für sie ein besonderer tag es
ist ihre erste vermutlich einzige
angelobung es ist doch meine erste
angelobung hier und ich darf meiner
freude darüber ausdruck verleihen dass
das möglich gemacht wurde aller
widrigkeiten zum trotz zwei tage vor
weihnachten platz vor einen weiteren
block kam dass es hier das erste mal im
jahr 2020 wieder zu einer ordentlichen
angelobung hier in der bootsklasse einer
in mistelbach kommt auch wenn natürlich
leider viele ehrengäste und angehörige
leider nicht dabei sein können ein gruß
an dieser stelle auch an alle die wir
live stream heute zu sehen
sehr geehrte rekruten für sie ist das
natürlich ein besonderer tag ein tag an
den sie sich gerne zurückerinnern werden
chopins und auch wenn das wetter heute
nicht mitspielt ich denke an die worte
des herrn aber wir haben ihnen zwei
versprechen gemacht und hat beide
eingehalten
ihre aufhebung ihrer guten leistungen so
zu sagen ist das gefühl dass ein
versprechen eingelöst werden konnte mich
was die ausbildungen werden zur zeit
abgeschlossen werden konnte vor
weihnachten noch dass sie hier nicht
aber tatsächlich im dezember schnee
gesehen haben dieses versprechen konnte
das heute die kontakte zum lieben gott
nicht besser sehen was das wetter angeht
ich denke so weit reichen dank auch die
beziehungen bisher jungs konnten nicht
aber ich glaube trotzdem es könnte
schlimmer sein und ich denke wir werden
uns alle auch noch lange auf die hörner
daran zurückerinnern also heute geregnet
hat aber es hätte auch anders sein
können und wenn wir heute versucht sind
ein bisschen darüber zu jammern dass wir
nicht unsere üblichen gepflogenheiten
zwischen täglichen dingen die wir in
unsere marken wahrnehmen könne aufgrund
der pandemie und in einer situation die
man sage nicht gewünscht haben und noch
so einer krise wie wir sie schon
jahrzehntelang nicht erleben mussten
dann relativiert sich vieles
ich denke wir haben schlimme zeiten
erlebt und gewerbe vielleicht auch noch
von neuwagen erleben und wir müssen alle
die glauben welche situation gemeistert
situation machen machen es ist sicher
weil es für die sind wir im rahmen ihres
gesetzes auch werden
oberst schon angesprochen
einige von ihnen persönlich kennenlernen
könnten waren des assistenzeinsatzes als
sie sehen wir zwei wochen im staat sei
nicht sogar ein hohes maß an
sozialkompetenz an den tag legen durften
eine hohe professionalität eine hohe
disziplin bei den massen testungen als
wir in isselburg dienst an der
bevölkerung gemacht haben
mit einer freundlichkeit mit einer
souveränität wie es die alten markt das
ist eigentlich ein bisschen traurig dass
es krisen nicht die krone party braucht
dass auch menschen die sonst den
bundesheer vielleicht nicht so positiv
eingestellt sind plötzlich nicht mehr
daran zweifeln wie wichtig es ist ein
schlagkräftiges bundesheer zu haben auch
und vielleicht auch besonders in
friedenszeiten
ich bin dankbar dass wir in mistelbach
nicht nur eine schulstadt sind und eine
einkaufsstadt sind dass wir eine
kulturstadt sind sondern ich bin auch
sehr stolz darauf und dankbar dafür dass
mistelbach eine garnisonsstadt ist
ich bin dankbar dass ist
das aufklärungsbataillon drei gibt und
dass wir eine kaserne haben auf die wir
stolz sein können
ich bin dankbar dafür dass sie hier in
mistelbach jetzt im rahmen ihrer
stellung oder nicht ihrer stellung
sondern im rahmen ihrer angelobung jetzt
hier dienst machen dürfen ich hoffe dass
sie mistelbach in vielerlei hinsicht in
positiver erinnerung behalten werden
und ich wünsche ihnen alles gute und
auch im rahmen des bevorstehenden
weihnachtsfestes hoffe ich dass sie eine
schöne zeit verbringen wunsch ihnen
frohe weihnachten einen guten rutsch
alles gute und greifen sie gesund
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dafür berliner regional stark gebracht
von der militärmusik niederösterreich
es folgte die ansprache des kommandanten
republikaner brigadier christian arbeit
begeistert sagt der bürgermeister jurist
geschätzte damen und herren ich darf
mich bei ihnen bedanken dass sie unserer
einladung gefolgt sind und ihren die
sagen angelogen teilnehmen und ich darf
mich anfangs auch bei all denjenigen
bedanken wir hier entsprechend die
umrahmung sorgen mit dem militär muss
ist auch die abordnung des
kameradschaftsbundes es war ein
eigenartiges jahr das jahr 2020
keiner von uns hat sich im jänner dieses
diesen jahres vorstellen können welche
dinge auf uns zukommen und das
bundesheer gesprochen
das bedeutet noch dann militärische
hilfe briten überreichen
mobil machen
[Musik]
durchführung von massen helfen lehren
aus der zeit von 1600 soldaten die
tagtäglich diese geschäfte zulässig
seien bemerkenswert ist ja einiges auf
den kopf und sie unsere sind in dieses
bundeswehr rückkehr des bundes hat sich
sehr verändert in diesem jahr wurde sehr
oft sichtbar was das wesen und die
organisation aus max ist straff
organisiert haben sie hat ihr achim sie
ist in der lage kurzfristig aufgaben zu
übernehmen und system ist vorzugehen
und egal in welcher aufgabenstellung es
sich handelt das bundesamt entsprechen
konnte stützen und profil zeigen und
betreffen der umweltdienst ist
betreffend der ist ein unbedingtes
werden
orientieren das kann viel passieren
ich denke jetzt gleich wieder besser
gehen der grundwehrdienst betrifft
in dieser quasi stehen sie im einstieg
des lebens auf das fahrpersonal des
personals hat alles versucht die denn
wir verschiedene dinge mitzugeben seines
handwerklichen fähigkeiten aber auch
werte deutlichen fähigkeiten kennen sie
bedient man ein gewehr wie lässt hat man
erste hilfe was ist formal disziplin
alle diese dinge kennen sie und des
weiteren haben sie auch angelernt
bekommen verschiedene innere werte und
werte kategorie
ich kenne einige davon wie disziplin
gehorsam kameradschaft sie werden es
bald erkennen dass es anschließend
hielten sie große organisation
funktioniert genau diesen handwerklichen
fähigkeiten machen was du uns hier aus
hat es
wir sind die guten den kunden angeboten
haben
das einwerfen gefehlt haben
es gebe auch andere möglichkeiten
sondern der gesellschaft
ich bin fest davon überzeugt dass sie
verschiedene art und weise noch
gebraucht werden und verschiedenste
einsätze erfüllen werden egal wo sie
hinkommen in welcher funktion als axel
garbers sanitäter als fahrer oder
ähnliches es braucht alle diese
funktionen damit dass ein großes thema
des politisch bundesheer funktioniert
ich möchte macht die gelegenheit
wahrnehmen um mich beim fahrpersonal zu
gedanken für den einsatz auf der zwei
und drei sind vorbildliche verband ist
kümmert sich um die jungen rekruten
besten gekümmert
das handwerkszeug mitgegeben hat ich
möchte ja oft gelinge erfahren immer
noch nicht bei den eltern verwandten
freunden zu bedanken die leider heute
nicht hier sein können weil sie unseren
jungen rekruten auch ein entsprechendes
stütze sind entspannt zu sein werden
durch diese vermutlich für den einen
oder anderen herausfordernde oder
schwierige zeit
ich hatte eine kundin junge soldaten
ivan sichere mehr arbeiten sie sich
selbst zur erhaltung dieser werte damit
dass sie damit zur erhaltung des
gesamten beitragen ich wünsche einen
erfolgreichen dienst beim bundesheer
mögen viele ein prägende erlebnisse im
positiven sinne für sie stattfinden und
ich danke noch mal dass sie sich zu
diesem dienst bereitstellen für diesen
dienst bereitstellen und diese
herausforderung auch an dem es leben
unsere jungen soldaten
es lebe das österreichische bundesheer
[Applaus]
meine sehr geehrten herrn geschützte
festgäste junge kameraden wir kommen nun
zum eigentlichen höhepunkt dieses fest
das wird in kürze das feldzeichen
vortreten und der eingeprägten und das
ist das treuegelöbnis gesprochen
[Musik]
aus dem ganzen dorf martin reich aus dem
bezirk gänserndorf mistelbach institut
durchaus alle cruz nicole an zugenommen
der rekruten sprachen ich gelobe ich
glaube mein vaterland wada die republik
österreich republik österreich und sein
volk zu schützen und sein volk zu
schützen und mit der waffe zu
verteidigen und verteidige ich gelobe
oder den gesetzen und den gesetzmäßigen
behörden
neue universum zu leisten
[Musik]
5 durch ungenau zu gefunden
und genauso betreut und mit all meinen
kräften der republik österreich und dem
österreichischen volk zu dienen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ihre guten sich eingetreten das
feldzeichen eingetreten es folgt nun die
niederösterreichische wanderführer und
danach das erbitten und weitere befehle
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ganze
[Musik]
was kein cent
zur meldung und regale kommen sagt
frontzeck
ich hoffe dass die behinderung der
feierlichen angelobung von sicheren
bessere viele abgeschlossen
das ganze
während gestellt und zwar stets
feldzeichen das ganze
[Musik]